your first gut reaction is that you want
to help a child has gone missing so
everyone came with best intention that
created a sense of chaos and a sense of
competition if you have Madeline let her
come home to her mommy daddy brother and
sister too many cooks all
well-intentioned spoiling the the broth
of the initial investigation on the bad
feeling the lack of translation ability
those things have not been fundamentally
addressed
the secret report describes the
Portuguese police investigation as
haphazard it fell short it says of the
performance that would be expected of
any British force but the initial search
for Madeleine McCann was also hampered
by police and other agencies in the UK
says the report they fought a turf war
in a rush to get involved and caused
lasting damage to the Portugal UK
relationship according to the reports
author when this happened your first gut
reaction is that you want to help a
child has gone missing and SIOC we were
no different than anyone else so there's
this rush to help in the early stage and
I think because the UK did not have a
structure for dealing with this so
everyone came with best intention that
created a sense of chaos and a sense of
competition people putting their hand up
to help and wanting to help and in many
instances in my opinion wanting to be
seen to help the report outlines the
many organizations involved and some of
the problems caused the McCanns home
police force Leicester Shearer took over
all control of the UK response but was
ill-equipped to deal with such a big
investigation the force was put in
charge by the Association of Chief
Police officers a bad decision according
to the report the Portuguese were also
being offered advice by mr. Gamble's own
organisation co-op the Metropolitan
Police the Serious Organised Crime
Agency and the National policing
improvement agency the Crimestoppers
charity set up its own appeal hotline at
the same time it's understood the Prime
Minister and other ministers that the
Home Office and the Foreign Office were
demanding briefings with so many
contacts the Portuguese authorities were
apparently left confused and uncertain
who exactly they should be dealing with
in the UK
I've no doubt that relationships from
the outset with the Portuguese and were
impacted by it and I think that had a
long-term negative effect on the
investigation and I think to this very
day and the metropolitan police
investigation team that's that's engaged
now are still having to manage and
massage that relationship and perhaps to
be fair to the Portuguese mend some
fences that were trodden on in the early
days mr. gamble wrote the Home Office
report the scoping review when he was
head of C up the child exploitation and
Online Protection Centre today he runs
his own safety advice and Technology
business his northern competition was it
sort of into false rivalry I think if we
look at it honestly and there were some
in leadership roles who wanted to
represent their organization and be seen
or their organization be seen to take a
lead role and provide critical input in
this and that made it difficult for a
small regional force like Leicestershire
who you know they will say they came to
London you know walking about from
agency to agency trying to to lay this
off co-op certainly didn't have the
capacity and/or the in-house expertise
to deal with it given its size and focus
and I mean we we ended up in the long
term where we perhaps should have been
in the beginning but in Metropolitan
Police the issue is highlighted by the
authors of a new book looking for
Madeleine which is to be published next
week it was a case of too many cooks all
well-intentioned and spoiling the the
broth of the initial investigation and
then the mistakes or should I say
missteps began to pile one upon another
the problems that grew out of that race
to help in the initial phase of a
Madeleine investigation the problems of
lack of coordination between the
Portuguese police and the British police
the bad feeling the lack of translation
ability those things have not been
fundamentally address
Lester shear police were given the lead
UK role because that's the county where
the McCann family lives it was their
local forces job to explore and pass on
to the Portuguese any potential evidence
in Britain the report says that a
regional police force such as Lester
sheer simply wasn't up to the job but it
never questioned its appointed role as
the UK's Madeline coordinator but the
force and other agencies did frequently
question the way the Portuguese
authorities went about their
investigation and that says the report
led to accusations that the UK was
acting as a colonial power that early
bad feeling led to the sacking of the
original Portuguese detective chief gong
solo Amaral he was fired after
suggesting in an interview that British
police were not independent and appeared
to be working for the McCanns
and this year Scotland Yard accused the
Portuguese of being bureaucratic and
slow in their cooperation over the
current Metropolitan Police
investigation in the Algarve the
sensitivity of the relationship has not
gone away in the seven years since
Madeleine vanished from time to time you
see some signs that and they're working
well together but equally you're always
conscious even in interviews like this
of saying the wrong thing in case the
wrong person in Portugal is offended by
it and then you know people decide to
lift their toys and go home and I I'm
sure the Mekons as parents watching this
have been really sensitive to that
in his report mr. gamble urged the
setting up of a round-the-clock UK
police centre to respond in a more
coordinated way to missing children here
and abroad I'm not confident that that
there would be and because if you look
back to you know the aftermath of this
one of the critical recommendations from
the scoping review is that we created a
single national centre that whether you
were in Birmingham Belfast or Barcelona
and your child went missing under these
type of circumstances you'd have a place
you could call that place would have
access and to engage social media to
engage other agencies to engage the
Highways Network very much to pull
together an Amber Alert Plus type
scenario and but give you good advice at
the time and begin the engagement with
the overseas jurisdiction
but that hasn't happened
and the man who once led the UK's Child
Protection Law enforces isn't confident
that if another Madeleine McCann
vanished in similar circumstances the
response would be any better but in
Brunton Sky News